the legal and political worlds are
reacting forcefully to president Trump's
controversial pardon of Joe Arpaio the
former sheriff of Maricopa County
Arizona was convicted last month of
criminal contempt for violating a
judge's order not to detain people
suspected of being undocumented
immigrants Arpaio was to be sentenced in
October he faced up to six months in
jail joining us from our Washington
bureau to discuss the pardon is Jonathan
Turley a law professor at George
Washington University Jonathan good
morning thank you you know we've seen
presidential pardons before this isn't
new but why is this one unusual what's
unusual a number of respects first it's
very early presidents often get to
pardon work towards the end of their
terms particularly when they're heading
out the door and the second reason is
that this is a relatively minor offense
you're talking about sentencing that
would be equivalent to a misdemeanor
third presidents usually wait until
after sensing to see what accord
ultimately hands down in terms of
punishment all of those things obviously
were departed from here the biggest
difference is that it does appear that
President Trump circumvented the normal
process it does not appear that the
Department of Justice and their pardon
office a wade in here or signed off on
this pardon and that's important because
the Justice Department is in a position
to look at these cases and put them in
context that the Department of Justice
has specific guidelines for pardons does
it not I mean and it's a prep but is a
president bound by those guidelines it's
not the pardon power is almost absolute
I say almost because there's a
limitation on its use in cases of
impeachment but what is troubling for
some of us about this pardon is not the
application to the immigration
controversy the most troubling thing is
that this is really about the rule of
law a court issued an order to a sheriff
he disobeyed that order not just for a
week it's not like he did a couple of
arrests and getting finally got the
message he ignored it for 17 months
and it's very important for police
officers to comply with court orders
they sign warrants they limit abuse it's
a dangerous world if law enforcement
just flagrantly disregards those orders
and maybe not even just law enforcement
what about the message that this sends
to other government officials as you
talk about the fact that this was a
disregard well it sends a troubling
message and it's certainly not going to
help president Trump's greatly
deteriorated relationship with the
judiciary I mean for judiciary this is
the coin of the realm a judicial order
and compliance with orders is what holds
our system together now having said that
in fairness to the administration other
presidents have engaged in political
pardons Bill Clinton abuse pardons to a
far greater degree he used it for his
own family his friends political donors
frankly it was pretty disgusting at the
end of his term but this is nonetheless
troubling in a different way I you know
the thing that holds us together is a
nation committed to the rule of law is
our belief that we comply with these
types of court orders we can appeal them
we can disagree with them we can
challenge them but you comply as long as
they're valid for a law enforcement
official to disregard a court order is a
dangerous thing no Lawrence tribe who's
a fellow constitutional law professor at
Harvard said Friday our pyo's pardon
gives the middle finger to courts and
the Constitution and signals total
contempt for the rule of law and for
human decency well you know I think
Larry's point is is a good one I think
that we have to move beyond the subject
and the controversy underlying this case
we can disagree about immigration but we
have to play by the rules and the most
important one is that we have a court
system to challenge these types of
things now it's true this is an 85 year
old man the first is someone who had not
committed an earlier offender has spent
a lot of time in public service all of
that is factored in generally at
sentencing and indeed President Trump
could have simply negated the sentence
he could have allowed this to go forward
if he did that our pile could could
appeal his conviction but not face any
jail time
those are the types of things that the
Justice Department weighs in on as they
go to a president say look these are
your options but I have to say I would
be very surprised if the professionals
at the Justice Department would have
recommended this pardon I would expect
the president would have gotten a great
deal of opposition from the Justice
Department these people have got to go
into court and they tell judges we will
comply with what you say this part does
not say that thank you thank you
Jonathan didn't mean to cut you off
there running out of time we appreciate
the perspective thank you